ever since I spoke with Tina selig on
the podcast a few years back I find
myself reflecting on so many of the
insights she provided but Tina's
statement you need to question the
questions that you ask because those
questions determine the frame into which
answers will fall is one that has
fundamentally changed the way I look at
problems and the way I approach
Solutions Tina has become a good friend
and continues to mentor and enlighten me
in addition to the many roles I share in
her introduction Tina now serves as the
executive director of the night Hennessy
Scholars Program at Stanford which is an
amazing academic opportunity for
graduate students across disciplines on
our campus enjoy this best of episode
recorded during quarantine and enjoy the
wisdom and creative Sparks Tina
provides there you are staring at the
blank screen what do I say how do I say
it where do I start if you're like like
many of us having to communicate in
high-stake situations can really zap
your creative juices finding inspiration
and catalyzing your creativity can
really
help hi my name is Matt Abrahams and I
teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast today I am thrilled to be joined
by Tina celik who is a professor of the
practice in the department of management
science and Engineering at Stanford
University she is also a faculty
director at the Stanford technology
Ventures program Tina teaches courses on
creativity Innovation and
Entrepreneurship she is the author of
many books including creativity rules
get ideas out of your head and into the
world and ingenious a crash course on
creativity Tina is a passionate student-
centered teacher who is just a Dynamo to
learn from welcome Tina it's a pleasure
to be here great thank you shall we Jump
Right In you bet so how can people
develop a more creative Innovative
approach to their
communication this is really really
important I know that you think about
this a lot and what I'm going to tell
you probably is something that you think
about all the time but my World opened
up dramatically when I realized the
power of story tell sure I I saw people
who were great communicators but what I
didn't realize is how they were using
storytelling to really effectively get
their message across so at this point I
teach storytelling tools and techniques
and the power of Storytelling in almost
every one of my classes because no
matter how exciting your idea is if you
can't tell a story that truly engages
other people and make people feel
excited about the idea the whole thing
is going to fall flat so what are one or
two of the things you teach in that
storytelling that really could help
everybody listening in great so I'm I'm
a huge fan of the story spine are you
familiar with that I am but why don't
you share with others yeah so the story
spine is super simple it starts out like
this once upon a time and every day and
of course that sounds familiar but it
essentially sets the stage for where you
are now you know once at a time and you
describe the problem and the
consequences of that problem and then
after that is until one day and that is
your intervention that's what you're
going to do that's going to change the
plot and after that it's because of that
and because of that and because of that
and because of that you can have as many
because of that that's essentially the
consequences of your intervention and it
ends with and ever since then okay and
so it then paints a picture of the world
after your intervention has essentially
been adopted by the world so it goes
once upon a time in every day until one
day and because of that and because of
that and because of that until finally
and ever since then now it sounds really
really simple but it's actually quite
difficult to do and so I give my
students I'll give them an opening
prompt like there once was a girl who
Dreamed a flying or you know it could be
some problem like you know there are 500
million people in the world who suffer
from some ailment and I set the stage
for a problem and then have them tell a
story and it's really amazing to see
them start mastering these skills that
allow them to then communicate the ideas
they come up with class the the ideas
they come up with in class to really uh
share those ideas in a really compelling
way I really like leveraging the story
spine in that way I use the story spine
as as an example of the power of
structure in communication in general
and what's so cool about the story spine
is that it really invites that
creativity from the get-go and it
requires you to really stay focused on
your audience and their needs to my mind
one of the most important things of any
storytelling is making sure that you
engage the audience and make it relevant
to them and that approach that you take
puts that at the Forefront so that's
really powerful yeah I I also one of the
other things I I think is extremely
important is to think about the hook at
the beginning of the story and there's
so many ways to have a great hook it
could be a really surprising fact it can
be um something funny it can be a
question in fact I usually like to start
with a question a provocative question
because it it very clearly engages the
audience in thinking about wow how would
I answer that question that's a really
provocative question so Tina I am
literally picking up my soap box I am
putting it down and now standing on top
of it because you just touched something
that is so important to me I am on a
personal mission to have people stop
starting their presentations in meetings
with hi my name is and today I'm going
to tell you about that is so banal so
boring and what you just mentioned about
how to start in a provocative engaging
way can dramatic rically change an
interaction a communication and it
certainly helps in storytelling so thank
you for giving me an opportunity to
share that that we have to change the
way we start because it just it puts
people in a in a position of passiveness
and disengagement if we don't do it
right I I I completely agree in fact
here's a fun thing that you might want
to try in your classes as well uh just a
couple years ago we started a new
program and the students would go around
the room and introduce themselves and
they do this like I'm Joe Schmo and I
study this and my research is that and
everybody's you know snoring so we
switched around one of the students
started using a different framework and
it caught on and this is the framework
she started out saying imagine a world
where and then she would talk about you
know imagine world where we travel to
space as frequently as we get on an
airplane and then she'd say and my name
is so and so and this is what I'm
excited about and this is what I'm
studying that's going to help me get
there
and so we now do that in all the
introductions the students all have to
start out with what they're passionate
about imagine a world where and then
they have to start with that before they
tell anyone who they are or what they're
studying I love that I love that and it
dovetails nicely with what I teach which
is start like you're an action movie all
action movies start with action and then
you learn the title of the movie and the
credits and and what you're doing in
those introductions is the same thing
start by getting people passionate and
engaged and then you can introduce
yourself I love it I love it so my next
question has to do with what we spoke
about in the introduction to this
podcast about feeling stuck about how
and where to start when we create a high
stakes communication what advice and
guidance do you have for sparking our
creativity and getting us started in on
our
communication yeah that's a really good
question as with most problems the best
place to start is with a real really
understanding the needs and this starts
with asking questions so sparking
communication starts with asking why or
what or how and so having a mindset of
curiosity opens the door to great
communication and the more questions you
ask the more you learn the more engaged
you will be with others yeah I think a
lot of us go into these things saying I
have to say all this or this is my time
limit and I feel a lot of pressure and I
I really like this idea of asking
questions do you have do you have other
advice on question asking oh my goodness
I spent a lot of time in my classes
teaching students how to ask questions
the question you ask is the frame into
which an answer will fall and this night
sound like what are you talking about
but I can give you some really
interesting examples that hopefully will
just like blow your mind and make you
realize how powerful this is I would
love for you to do that I'd love to hear
some examples because that statement
about the frame sounds very zen-like so
I'd love to hear what it means it is
actually it's I mean it's it's so core
to everything we do uh I can give you
several examples in fact let's start
with a simple example okay um I could
ask you uh to build a bridge and you can
go off and build that bridge or you
could come back and say well Tina why do
you need a bridge and i' say well I need
a bridge to get the other side of a
river and you go wow well there are lots
of ways to get to the other side of the
river I mean what Matt how many other
ways are there to get to the other side
of a river what could you do I could
think of three or four different ways
right away get a boat swim across things
like that right exactly a tunnel a hot
air balloon you know all sorts of ways
to get across so if I ask a question do
you want to I how to get across the
river it's a really different solution
set than how do you build a bridge but
my favorite example is when I use in my
classes where I have the students um
come up with all the things they hate
about their suitcase of course we're not
using as many suit cases right now but
they're not traveling as much but you
know what are all the things and they
quickly make a list of oh it's too heavy
the clothes get wrinkled the wheels get
locked the handle doesn't work all sorts
of things you know it's not the right
size and so I go okay great go design
now a brand new suitcase and they come
back with all these new fancy suitcases
with all of these new features and they
think they've done their a good job
until I say did we ask the right
question H because the real question is
why just like why do you need a bridge
you know why do you need to go across a
river the question is why do you need a
suitcase uhhuh now so the the initial
answer people think I'm just being
flippant and they well you know to carry
my stuff but that's actually not why you
use a
suitcase nobody likes to carry a
suitcase we use a suitcase despite the
fact that we hate packing it we hate
dragging it around we hate it getting
lost we hate storing it and yet we use
it and we assume that we need a suitcase
but the real reason when you start going
down that rabbit hole you start
realizing the real reason you use a
suitcase is to have the things you need
at your Des destination mm sure so how
might you solve that problem and they
look at me and go well well that's kind
of interesting how might I solve that
problem and I urge them to think not
just today but what could you do in five
years or 10 years or 50 years to solve
this problem so you could say well what
if I had 3D printed clothes essentially
my closet you know had a a virtual
closet in the cloud okay so that when I
get to my destination I go gosh I really
wish I had a jacket I'm going a print my
down jacket or gosh I really wish I had
hiking boots and i' print them out and
at the end of your trip you kind of melt
them back down they go back up in the
cloud or maybe there's a airbn be for
clothes right you go somewhere and you
rent all your clothes and then you give
them back or maybe your suitcase maybe
you have one suitcase that travels
around the world independent of you and
you just go online and say suitcase go
to Paris suitcase go to Rome you know
and it follows you so the the fact is
that you need to question the questions
you ask and this is one of the most
powerful things you can do to unlock
really really innovative solutions well
first I'd love to live in that reality
because I hate slipping suitcases but
second the the idea that we have to
question our questions to spark
creativity can help in not just creating
communication but I think in lots of
facets of our life thank you for sharing
that as you've just demonstrated you're
a master teacher and I know you have
embraced virtual teach in as many of us
are having to do can you share best
practices you've developed that can help
all of us as we communicate more and
more remotely you bet um I I think about
this a lot it is a really different
learning environment and a virtual
classroom is quite different than an
in-person class I'm trying to figure out
how do I make that experience as
powerful as possible for the students
and one of the first things you have to
think about is setting the stage right
and when you go into a classroom and
it's one of the reasons I teach to the
dchool is the space is so great and I
can set the stage for a class but since
I can't do that online how can I set the
stage and so I do it in a number of
different ways one is I always start my
classes off playing music and I play
some upbeat music so that everyone
starts out actually sort of like dancing
you know everyone's bopping around
before we start the class it sets the
stage it sort of allows us to know we're
now moving into the classroom then we
turn off the music we start the other
thing is I often have the students we
all decide where we're going to go
they're like okay this week we're gonna
meet in Antarctica and everybody changes
their backdrop to a picture from antara
we're gonna go to New Zealand and so
there's just a fun way of getting
everyone in the space and you sort of
set the stage the fact that you're
together you've all listened to the same
music you have the same background and
you're now ready to dive in also I think
it's really important to change up
activities really quickly like every 10
to 15 minutes I almost feel it's almost
like Sesame Street you know every 10 to
15 minutes you need to change you know
watching a video to doing an activity to
uh breaking into small groups you know
folks get bored looking at a screen if
things are static so you need to plan a
lot in advance I view myself as more of
a producer when I'm planning an online
class there's a tremendous amount of
thought that goes into essentially
script
the whole experience so I the the point
about setting atmosphere up front I I
think can make a really big difference
you're doing it with music and common
backgrounds but just taking time to
think about how do we set the tone for
what we want this communication
experience to be like is really
important and your colleague Bob Sutton
and I talked very similarly about
switching things up every 10 to 15
minutes and that's really important and
that notion you mentioned actually was
just something I highlighted recent Rec
when I was asked about teaching and
presenting virtually and that notion of
being a producer so we often think hey I
just have to focus on my meeting
contribution or this the agenda or my
presentation but when you're presenting
virtually you have to have this other
task to focus on which is the production
aspect the timing of it when do I do
things do I have things lined up so it
can be an added burden but if done well
it can really change the engagement and
the whole interaction can be much more
powerful and memorable exactly one of
the other things I do is I always have a
check-in with the students and it's
interesting I used to do it in my classs
where we'd stand in a big circle and
everybody would get say a sentence about
what's going on in their life and it
might be oh I'm gonna go to Yos this
weekend or I've got a big exam after
this or I just have a job interview
whatever it is but guess what I can do
this now on a zoom whiteboard and it
happens really efficiently everyone can
kind of populate it I can ask a
different question like what are you
looking forward to or what's your best
quarantine treat or you know anything
you want and people will quickly
populated and you get this wonderful
snapshot of where everyone in the class
is at the moment I I again it's bringing
people into the mo into the room setting
the tone in the mood and you and I uh
were talking about just before we
started recording this podcast this
notion that people are so focused on on
the the deficiencies and the things
we're missing in the virtual environment
when in fact there are some things that
can actually help and that notion of
using a tool like a whiteboard uh that's
collaborative is something that would be
really hard to do in person yet
virtually we can do it so so taking time
to embrace what this environment can
allow us to do I think is also very
important I couldn't agree more there
are some things that actually work much
better on online than they do in person
and of course there's some things that
have been you know sacrificed but to
look at the things that work well as
opposed to things that don't mhm
absolutely you know you have had amazing
opportunities to interview and work with
lots of entrepreneurs do you have any
key insights or takeaways that you've
gleaned over the years that you could
share with us that we could benefit from
oh sure there are so many uh one that
comes to mind is that failure is a
normal part of the onpro journey and
that if you're doing something that's
really Innovative really hard that no
one's done before there are bound to be
false starts and missteps so you need to
be prepared for setbacks and you need to
think of failure as an opportunity to
redirect your energy and attention and
that's really important is having a
mindset of of resilience and and
bouncing back another one is then the
end all you have is your reputation if
others don't trust you if they don't
find you to be authentic then it's going
to be really difficult to bring your
ideas to life you need to make sure that
you spend time thinking about your
values and make sure that you up hold
them so that uh you can build a
community that really is supportive and
trusting and works really well
together and my favorite lesson is that
there is a huge benefit in seeing
problems as opportunities and with that
mindset the world is opportunity Rich
it's full of possibility uh essentially
entrepreneurs are ultimately optimists
who are able to see and sees
opportunities that others don't
immediately see in fact if you come to
our office at the Stanford technology
Ventures program you'll see painted on
the walls in very big letters on one
wall it says every problem is an
opportunity the bigger the problem the
bigger the opportunity and on another
wall it says entrepreneurs do much more
than imaginable with much less in seems
possible and these are the mindsets I
think that are extremely important and
that very successful entrepreneurs have
embodied them wow those are really
powerful lessons and they Echo very
nicely some of the topics that we've
covered on the podcast in terms of
failure and reputation and reframing
things uh not as problems but
opportunities and and all of us can
benefit from reflecting on that and and
using those as a way to guide us as we
are entrepreneurial and whatever our
endeavors are so thank you for sharing
those before we end I'd like to ask you
the same three questions that I ask
everyone who joins me are you up for
that sure excellent all right well
question number one if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you've ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title what would
that
be wow that's so interesting I I'm GNA
hearken back to what we talked about
before and I would say know your first
and last words when you are giving a
talk you should know where you're
starting and nail it and have that
opening line or the opening story
completely set and you should know the
last wordss uh everyone knows in the
middle it can sort of uh it can move a
little bit more organically but by able
to like nail the first last words you
end up uh really engaging people in a
way that they know where you are they
know where you're going and they're with
you until the end that is such profound
and useful advice uh a lot of people get
nervous so they really focus on what
they they want to say first but many
people just figure when I get to the end
I'll just know how to wrap it up and and
I'll tell you in all my work that I do
the most frequent ending I hear is uh I
guess we're out of time thanks exactly
exactly ridiculous or they just sort of
Trail off at the end and turn around and
walk off the stage right so so that
advice very sagely uh not not only
should you you know the first words but
also those last words great let me ask
you question number two
and I'll be very curious to hear your
answer about uh to this who is a
communicator that you admire and
why oh we have had so many amazing
speakers I think the most compelling
speaker I have heard on our stage is
Salon founder of Academy he is the only
speaker in the series that has ever
received a standing ovation wow his
storytelling ability is incredible he's
super funny he's really humble and he
used such motivating examples that
everyone was sitting on the edge of
their seat um I have to say I just
aspire to being as such a masterful
Storyteller and Communicator as he
is very cool I I have seen him speak and
I completely agree and I have to fess up
to something he actually exercises at
the same gym that I belong to and I have
wanted to go up to him but I am way too
intimidated so oh he's so humble you
should just go say hello I will but I'm
often really sweaty anyway but uh no
he's a he's a great he's a great speaker
and and a great guy I said I told you to
do it okay I'll say Tina told me and and
I've learned in my life Tina that if I
follow your advice good things happen so
thank you all right question number
three uh what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe well you know
what's interesting I I do a lot of
public speaking and I did a little
exercise a couple of years ago I project
called 60 weeks to 60 and in the 60
weeks up until my 60th birthday I gave
myself different challenges and one of
them was that I went to a professional
speaking
coach and she was amazing she watched
videos of My Talking and some of the
most important things I learned from her
were to Stand Tall you know just hold
the space sometimes I mean there's a
tendency to want to rush through what
you're what you're saying and to kind of
be feel like somehow you're taking up
people's time but they're there to hear
you so you want to stand tall slow down
and tell a
story those three bits of advice are
fantastic helpful and direct and many
people if they were to take time to
watch their videos uh and have others
give them feedback would note exactly
what you learned that these are things
that that we often don't do and yet make
a big difference Stand Tall slow down
tell a story great advice and and Tina
the whole conversation was fantastic
thank you as I as I knew would be the
case your insights and ideas about
creativity and communication were were
spoton very helpful and everyone
listening can benefit from taking the
bits of advice you shared into practice
and and really thinking about how they
themselves can be both creative and
Innovative thank you so much thank you
you it's been a pleasure thank you for
listening to think fast talk smart the
podcast a production of Stamford
Graduate School of Business to learn
more go to gb. stanford.edu please
download other episodes wherever you
find your
podcasts